okay
for people joining this live stream we
are looking
at game theory design for language
it's the second meeting in our recent
series we had discussed this several
years ago
but now it looks like we are uh really
getting this together and getting it
ready for
sort of full implementation in the
system
so last time we had
gone through some of this material and
uh we um
uh i think had discussed
a bunch of kind of game equilibria
as i as i recall um but we were
going on can you joseph can you remind
us where we got to
yes so uh we were touching the
replicator dynamics
and also the learn strategies and we
were not discussing the collisional
games
okay so let's just do a little bit of a
refresher here
so the concept
that we discussed previously was this
concept with game object
although you know one thing that
troubles me about that
there's a completely different meaning
for the term game object
which may yet arise that is
more like the game object in the sense
of video games
um and and for example if we look at i
mean this is just a naming issue
but if we look at our uh things i don't
know
what's going to be the future of this
but but uh our um
uh let's take a look here oh why is that
not
why is that not coming up is roger here
can he perhaps
address that
i'm here but i can't say why the search
system doesn't work
actually i'm using 12.3 here let me try
using 12.2
it's always dangerous to use software
from the future
[Music]
okay let's take a look here
do you know what the what the objects in
unity link are called
game objects what's going on here so
this needs to be reported
yep
this is really outrageous
i think i know what this is i think it's
because when the paclet hasn't been
loaded
there's no evidence of its existence
which is just totally wrong and
i think we've been through this before
just totally wrong
[Music]
okay
okay
okay so we've got things like unity game
object here
so unfortunately there are different
meanings of the word game
so is there a way to qualify what we
mean by a game
here other than a game theory game which
is kind of a silly thing to say
yeah well a matrix game can refer to
matrix games no no i understand that but
but is there a more generic
term for a game theory game
um i mean it's it's just you can call it
a siri game instead of a game three game
what did you say yeah you can call it a
theory game or a theoretical game
or maybe a finite game
game model
finite game wouldn't work because
there's too many other things that are
finite games
yeah so i mean possibly
uh possibly we're talking here let's see
where am i taking these notes
this is this is probably do i have a um
did i start taking notes last time
game model game model object game
that seems more um
oh there is an sw001 maybe that's from
the previous iteration of all of this
work
go ahead okay so game model or
or game game theory
actually another possibility is game
theory object
which would make it very clear what it
is yeah that's not bad at all
yeah there is there is um
but i'm not entirely sure how far we'll
go in games
but these are finite games as opposed to
infinite games
but correctly there are more than one
meaning to finite
i know
um but it's unlikely that the
specification language generalized to
infinite gains
i understand that so okay so a
possibility is something about
uh finite gain but i'm skeptical about
it you know maybe maybe that will work
yeah maybe not maybe maybe the other
ones are
are having a prefix that's how we often
done the common case is short the
less common okay
you know like plot is short list plot is
longer
yeah so it could have been function plot
and plot
sure but so what what is your point here
yeah so maybe we'll come to that when we
add it later on
come to add what if we add infinite
games different
games maybe we they get the longer name
yeah yeah i understand i understand that
makes perfect sense but
but the question then is i just don't
think
game object just doesn't seem like the
right thing because
it's too close to what we're dealing
with in um
i mean okay we've got game or game
theory model is also possible
how does the game theory model thing
agree with
the way we use model in uh statistics
and potentially in other areas they're
related but not particularly close
there are many uses of model
you know we have optimization models too
but we don't call them models
yes in statistics we don't call them
only regression ones are called models
the distributions are models but we
don't call them
models i know we call them distribution
and the processes are also models but we
don't call them models
fair enough okay okay let's just review
though
how this is supposed to work here so i
think we agreed
last time uh so we've primarily got
these matrices
right but we also agreed that we need
the possibility of having associations
there so that you can name
the actions is that right yes
okay that's not reflected here though uh
no so so um
in the end i try to address some some
questions uh from the previous
uh meeting right okay but otherwise this
is more or less the same what was
uh previously so this i didn't even know
we really had these i mean
how many of these do we have do we have
these for other games i mean if i look
at um
uh i found it only for tic-tac-toe
but i don't even know what this means
for tic-tac-toe i mean it seems like
i don't understand this i mean the
tic-tac-toe game tree is
four thousand elements so i don't
understand what this is
i'm not sure uh it's it's trying to use
the cemetery to reduce the number of
distinct moves
i see okay that's kind of interesting in
its way
um okay
okay so what we've got here then
as i understand it i'm just trying to
remember how this all works
you've got this um
okay so so what's the idea with all of
these do we have a summary now
of all these various functions that
you're proposing or not yes
in the end i try to reduce
the number of functions to okay all
right here we go
so in the end there is these essential
objects and functions
okay
okay but but so then
here this first thing okay it's all the
same
creature that first thing is all the
same right
this this thing here right they're all
packaged together in the same object
correct
well it could be uh however there are
some
things like for for example the
collisional games
which could be under the same game
object but
if if there is a possibility that i
would separate them
well we'll have to figure out the
detailed design right so
so i mean the
the generic case go ahead and say we
haven't talked about all the
complications of
coalitional game right now i think it
would be nice if you could fit them in
but i can see that it'll be challenging
to fit them in and they might have to
have their own their own object type but
um
okay so then from game we are
taking we're looking at from this game
model or game object or whatever it's
called um
we're then
i mean it's possible look it's possible
that we could get away with
as roger is kind of implicitly
suggesting
calling this collection of things finite
game
and that would distinguish us from the
game object in the sense of video game
and allow us the possibility of having
different structures for for example
infinite games in the future
yes infinite or continuous or
differential those are all
relevant possibilities
so what would it be differential
differentiable
or continuous otherwise known as a
continuous game
is this is finite game also discrete
game
yeah yes
discrete it might be even better name
actually
oh maybe not
i'm just worried about things which are
in the set of finite game or discrete
game which are
not really included here because they're
just um
yeah they're you wouldn't try to address
them with this formalism you're not
going to try to put go
in this for example
right as well trying to find it discreet
games but
okay but so what is the characteristic
of i mean these games have the
characteristic that they have
they're modeled with matrices and things
is that true
yes so here every that there is a finite
number of players and every player has a
finite
number of possible actions
well so is the right name just matrix
game
or does that not capture some of the
types of games that people would
consider here
um i think uh some games are
more naturally represented in a game
tree form because if you try to
uh transform into a matrix form then
there are too big so it's better to
represent them in a in a tree structure
well so conceivably we would have
another we would have two cases then we
could have
game tree and matrix game
right and right now those are separate
things under the game
function i i see it right so i mean but
what i'm thinking is
if you say if you have a matrix game and
you say game tree of that
it would convert it to the tree form and
give you visualizations appropriate for
that
does that make sense uh yes
it's but it's more natural to go from
game three to matrix game
from from i understand it's not unique
and also computationally it can be very
demanding to
to do what to to to find an appropriate
game tree representation of a matrix
game
why
um
why well um um you can you can always
find one but there there are very much
non uh there is no uniqueness
in that um so it's not an equivalent
representation so you can't
no no the tree form is
is a richer representation in this in
this
this point of view and there's no
obvious default from a given matrix game
for its tree form no
there is a theorem that every matrix
game can be represented by
an incomplete informational
game tree but there is no
um canonical rewriting
okay okay all right i understand
okay so let's keep going here so so then
this stuff
what is the representation of the
equilibrium how do you
given that you have a let's say a matrix
game object
how do you represent the equilibrium
then
so in this initial implementation uh the
equilibrium is simply
a set of strategies which is a
probability distribution on the actions
for every player
so how do you represent that well here
are represented with nested lists
which which simply give
back probabilities which are uh positive
numbers
summing to one i see so in other words
whatever the
the original okay hold on i'm i'm
confused here there's a matrix
and then there's a state there's a
matrix representing the various payoffs
in the game
and then there's some particular state
which is the solution to the game
like there's a matrix and a vector you
know in linear algebra is that correct
um well if um if you have
n players and those have strategies then
the the equilibrium strategy for nash
equilibrium
is a set of probability distributions a
set of mixed strategies
uh on every action set
i understand i understand but the
dimensionality the game
is is if i'm understanding is the
outer product of the strategies
it's it's pl it's players and choices
but with probabilities attached to
each for the account handle the mixed
strategy case
right so you don't just have the option
of playing a or b you have the problem
the option of playing you know a with
probability is 0.67 and b with
probability 0.33
okay so how does that relate to our
categorical distribution stuff
roger or anybody else
uh well it's pretty much a categorical
distribution
okay so joseph you know what we're
talking about there
not precise no okay so we will go
through that but please
yeah i mean there's this function
categorical distribution which
represents exactly what you were just
describing
that is and that would give you a
natural way when you get to the
differentiable games
that will give you a natural way to
generalize this
right so this is a categorical
distribution which allows you to specify
probabilities for different uh
for different categorical outcomes you
could call them strategies or actions in
the case of games
right but the point is that i mean what
we're using and i have to say
this name categorical distribution is
starting to concern me
because the places we're using it it's
just a very bizarre complicated name
right i mean it's it's really a more
like a choice distribution or something
like this
categorical is awfully weird i mean
we're using it in quantum mechanics
for outcomes of quantum experiments
we're using it here
um we're now thinking about using it
here for strategies
what would you think about about this
being called choice
distribution
roger that's a um
it would be uncommon but it's not wrong
i know but the point is that we're using
it more generally
than just for statistics wonks you see
what i'm saying
yeah i mean we're going to end up using
it for um
uh you know
you know by the time it's being used in
in quantum mechanics
and particularly in like categorical
quantum mechanics
where the name categorical means
something utterly utterly different
right we know we're in bad shape
i mean i mean it's also not
inconceivable that we have
a few variants of this that sort of
tuned
yeah i agree to share i'm saying yeah so
long as sometimes they interconvert
properly
exactly as long as they do that but it
could be that their input methods and
other things that are more tuned
and makes it perfect for some right
but so so this in what you're saying
i have some state so so
you know here
sorry steven we we should think of that
state differently because some there are
games with intermediate states before
their
payoff outcomes these these games don't
have an internal state
we're only looking in the in the
solution space of strategies so it's not
really a game state in that sense
um it's just just yes
yes so this is usually referred to as a
strategy
i understand but okay so so do you have
a
right now the explicit form because i
mean
these we're not going to have all of
these at least i don't think we're going
to have
although i mean i could be convinced
otherwise these kind of special game
heads i mean you know i don't know does
does roger have an opinion about that i
don't know this field well enough to
know
whether it makes sense i don't know i
want us to
make it easy and we want a big
collection of those so you can get all
the standard games
exactly how we do that i'm not i haven't
really thought it through yet
changing strategy i think we yeah i
think it would be cleaner
cleaner if these are method option kind
of uh things um
rather than different heads um no no no
no no no no no
we're not probably not talking about the
same thing no we're talking about here
if there is a different way to specify a
bayesian game
and to specify i don't i just don't know
it's the i thought you meant things like
tic tac toe
no i didn't think that secretary talked
about bayesian games
as opposed to um perfect information i
see
the question is whether or not you want
to have the the information
parameters of the game be something
which is a different head or it's just
an
option
yeah i think beijing is a very strange
name for it too
um joseph can you comment on that i
can't comment
well yes so the bayesian game is a
standard thing
uh it's it's a textbook name for it
uh but for the previous question i think
uh the bayesian games
the the the matrix games and also in
some extent the
game trees can be packed together into
one
object uh so previously uh
stephen said that for example
interplayed functions can have different
uh inner life
and and in following that that
reasoning a game object can have
different
inner self uh so it can be a
matrix game a tree game or beijing
um presentation yes
but i mean i mean a bayesian game has no
one unique matrix representation it's
it's a different thing
but if we want to minimize the object
what we what we use
then it more or less it fits into the
into the game or the finite game
category
to define a bayesian game you need to
specify more things and you also need to
add a prior
on this and that we can go into that but
you you
you need to to specify more things
to define a beijing game
i found that this area is very much like
a russian novel
like everybody has three names
um you know that there are lots of names
textbook names there's not just one
there's like lots of textbook names
yeah that's always complicated in terms
of our naming efforts
yeah all right let's let's keep going i
think you'd wanted to talk about
different types of games here
um
let's see you would want to talk about
replicator dynamics which i don't
understand what it is
so where is the name first of all
does replicated dynamics come from from
people doing kind of biology inspired
games
or what uh yes so it's a it's a sub
branch of evolutionary game theory
okay okay fine and i think i know it's
at least it's history
okay fine i'm just i'm just i i have no
idea you know these things could come up
in
i don't know what you know legal
negotiation or something and it means
something utterly different
but no this is this is a standard thing
and and yes so this is on in the
intersection of biology and game theory
here basically you define
a fitness function uh
so you have you imagine that you have
some kind of population
which means that in this population
different
uh players or different replicators
full of different strategies let's say
different pure strategies
if they are selected to be player one
then they always
defect for example if we are talking
about um
prisoners still and the other and the
other
uh species is always
cooperating for example and then
uh you can ask that if you start to play
if one kind of replicator one kind of
strategy starts to play
this game in the given population then
what will be
the expected utility the expected gain
and based on that expected utility this
is what you
take as a fitness and and
as a function of that fitness it will
replicate
or shrink in numbers so there is hold on
hold on hold on so this is
is this happening in continuous time yes
okay so this is so one thing we can
imagine is an iterated game happening in
discrete time
where there are you know rounds of the
game
and people have different strategies
okay which can depend on the history so
in this case
this is a
so this is a continuous declaration
yes so this is this is this is
definitely a continuum limit of that of
that idealization that the the
populations are playing against each
other in exactly even groups there's no
probabilistic pairing
right and there's no discrete uh steps
so
it's okay limit of everything so this is
the sir model story
of um which you presumably could can you
in fact get
i mean is there a version of a
replicated dynamics game that is the sir
model of epidemiology
um i didn't see but i think it's
it's not i think it can be constructed
uh
so okay but so so essentially what this
is doing is it's generating a bunch of
odes what otherwise would be
discrete matrix operations become a
bunch of ods here
yes yes and
just one confusion that i have here is
okay so there's something dot you know
there's some
variable the time var time derivative
and that's what's being set equal to the
the game outcome is that correct is the
the rate of change is set equal to some
kind of game outcome
or what yes game outcome given the the
given the the proportions in the in the
um population yes
yeah so basically for for for given a
given uh species or a
subpopulation with a with a particular
strategy they're gonna get an average
fitness with this state of the
background population and their their
the fitness they got in terms of the
score they got playing everybody else
determines their rate of replication
right so is this related to population
dynamics
yes exactly yes this is population
dynamics on strategy okay so
those exist both in discrete time
continuous time
well it's a logistic map in in in
discrete time this could be things like
the logistic map yes which which game
theory is not well equipped to deal with
as i understand it or is that i mean
people have done this i know people do
this you could tell
them things yeah go ahead you could
definitely do this with discrete form
where you're just doing that
you know a game of all the list you know
versions of it where you're just doing
discrete steps and and
uh picking the pairings randomly or some
other way like that
um from step to step um there certainly
are discrete versions of this especially
in spatial form but even in non-spatial
form you can have a discrete version of
this okay but so i just so i understand
that i mean so
is it all population dynamics replicator
dynamics
or is it some i think this is most of
evolutionary game theory
is modeled in this way is that not
correct yes
there is there but so there is a zoo of
different replicator dynamics
this is the default what i implemented
here there are discrete
there are some uh with with some
stochastic
uh so so there is somewhere there
um diffusions between strategies
there are some which try to damp down
the oscillations what
probably you will see if you scroll down
etc so there is a whole
zoo of that but i think why it is
nice to implement those is because it
gives a time
horizontal of of equilibria and also um
but for instance could you take a food
web and simulate its dynamics
if you're doing it at the level of odes
yes yes
certainly but i mean i don't think
this is definitely used in ecology
models generally right including spatial
ecology models
but but well spatial is yet different
again because then
it's like people do you know cellular
automata with continuous variables and
things
in that case but then that's a whole you
know
that's look this roger this is very
similar to the
you know system model stuff in
engineering
right it's a it's a bunch of odes and
this one no of course yeah
now i recognize i'm just trying to
delineate what this is because i have a
whole
you know i have a yard on population
dynamics it's not a small area
right okay so the answer
i think is this there are class of
models that are pure odes
and perhaps there's even a subset of
those models i'm not sure
but i think there's a class of of sort
of everybody mixes with everybody ode
models
that this that's what this is covering
and i think the
you know all of the verbiage of
evolutionarily stable strategies and so
on which presumably
is one of the things that game solves
should be able to produce is that is
that correct
did i misunderstand
yes so so yes it somehow reminds me of
systems biology as well well
less so i think i mean this is more the
ecology story
well i i see what you're saying but
where you're actually computing
well that's more that's so close to the
system modeling where you're actually
getting
odes that represent chemical processes
and so on
but but so in this case okay
so the point here
i mean i'm a little bit concerned that
this is a bit of shoehorning
of a derivative being set equal to
you know the ordinary game case is
you you know you're specifying a
strategy
and you just get a definite result
here you're getting the result
as a time derivative that you're then
putting in and then solving the ode with
that time derivative so i'm not mistaken
i mean this is basically a way
there's basically a model construction
method for systems of odes for
things like ecology is that a true
statement
where the story that you tell so i mean
the microscopic story you tell is one of
individual games being played with
certain outcomes
yes the the reason this is what ties
back to game three and other ways
besides that is that the the particular
populations you define here
are often um differentiated by their
strategy in
a game space so it's like you can have
these things evolving where you know in
iterative
prison's dilemma one of the pot so
populations is things following the tit
for tat strategy
right um so the the the particular
strategies they're following are the
things that then have evolutionary
dynamics and evolutionary fitnesses and
take
over the system or don't take over the
system and that's the kind of stuff
you're
exploring the point is that the
selection is on something which is
defined by a game strategy
yes i mean to me i have to say my gut
feeling is that this is not the same
underlying function as the i mean that
what you would be doing is to say
yes you might have a whatever we're
calling it
you know a matrix game for example but
then this is some rapper
that's the that's the underlying kernel
but then this replicated dynamics thing
is a separate
uh is something that uses that kernel
but uses it in a different way than for
example game solve uses that kernel
yes exactly that's correct correct
that's correct
okay and there's going to be things like
that which are you know the replicator
dynamics can be different
the um the the population mixing can be
different the you know any spatial thing
can be different
right there's a couple things you know
just things which are typically done on
top of
that that kernel okay right here
i see so okay so we've got this notion
then
of i mean you know we've got yet another
potential
name for this concept is like a game
kernel
[Music]
which then well i don't know that's the
right name for it but um
uh
um
i noticed somebody on the live stream i
see commenting on whether this is
related to
why i was trying to i put out a strange
tweet about
the fact that i put my collection of
economics books on top
shelves which has made them extremely 20
years ago which made them extremely hard
to access
and they're asking well this is the
reason i was looking at those no it
isn't
that has to do with much more
foundational questions in economics that
i've been
curious about and making progress with i
should say but that has
so far as i know although it's a good
question to raise
so far as i know it has nothing to do
with this although it's actually a good
question to raise
um okay in any case all right so the
replicator dynamics takes one of these
kernels
and gives then
what interpolating functions or what as
the output
yes so these are the solutions of uh
nd solve functions this is the
appropriately nested list of
interpolating functions
and to be clear i mean you should have
one of those interpolating functions for
each sub-population here the
sub-populations are pure strategies but
they don't have to be the populations
can be defined in different ways
so so in other words what you're saying
in the previous case it might be a
choice distribution
is the output for a given
player's behavior so to speak in this
case
the output is an interpolating function
is that correct yes
and in many cases uh the the fixed point
of so the the game solve can give you
many possible solutions and
and this this
replicator dynamics usually or often has
a fixed point
and depending on the initial conditions
the fixed point will be usually one of
the
the solutions of the game so
in other words i understand the time
dependence
the asymptotics of this could be the
same as the
nash equilibrium it goes to a fixed
point yeah
which these ones are not yes these are
these ones are oscillating and as i
mentioned there are
there are other replicator dynamics
equations which
tried it tries to damp down these
oscillations and
fine i mean if you would start from the
equilibrium
uh the dynamics wouldn't go out from
there
so i mean for example just so i
understand for context the lot covaltera
equations
are an example of this replicated
dynamics or not
uh if i'm correct in the lot cobalt era
you
are not calculating proportions but but
absolute numbers but if you convert the
absolute numbers to proportions then yes
and so what is the strategy what is the
kernel of the luck of all terror
equations in this sense
you know fox eats rabbit or something or
and then what does that mean in terms of
a strategy here
i mean so in the case of rock paper
scissors for example it's just one is
beating another
right so you can have similar
relationships among your different
species and a lot for the
terrorist situation um so if if a
interacts with b
you have a deterministic outcome and one
is a positive one as a negative utility
and if those are all these
plus one and minus one you would get
something like this okay
all right fine but so so then the
wrapper that we need so jason here i
noticed that you
say utility and joseph says payoff
so that's another one of those two names
occurring repeatedly in the literature
yes technically the payoff is is for a
particular set of choices and for
the utility is an expectation of that
across your mixed strategy so
if you're if you're sometimes playing
this and somebody's saying that you're
sometimes getting this payoff and
sometimes getting that payoff and the
expectation of the two of them is your
utility and
yeah there are subtle distinctions like
that when you're talking about one move
or one shot of the game when you're
talking about an expectation
yeah here i think utility is more
precise so
so utility is something what is expected
that the
players want to maximize in uh so
the players want to maximize the
expectation of utility
and the payoff that it can be monetary
monetary or something
and this is not always equivalent to
to to utility so maybe you want to
maximize the logarithm of
of your monetary uh
reward and in that case you need to
transform the monetary payoffs to
to utility and then you can apply again
yeah that's fair especially in economic
context you'll have a mapping from
payoff to utility
independent of the uh expectation i'm
confused about something else
so in one case you say there's a choice
distribution certain probabilities for
different strategies
right is it the case that here when you
have this continuous value
in the replicator case then instead of
having a probability
you instead have just these continuous
valued outcomes
varying with time these are
these prob these uh vertical axes here
are the relation it's it's this is a
um this is a popular strategy
portion and stun right population in
that strategy uh these strategies i
think are here are currently um
fixed ones not mixed ones you can also
have this where you have mixed
uh strategies and the thing which is
evolving is what probabilities you put
on things those are different
those are different things right here
you're just changing the concentration
of the people following the strategy
strategy so do we get strategic
differential equations then
hold on let me just unwrap this so i
mean what you're saying here
is this is sort of a frequentest
interpretation of the choice
distribution
is that correct i mean we could as well
have said
there are different probabilities i mean
there's two things going on here one is
the continuous variation with time the
other is
that we are representing if i'm not
mistaken
you know these are the these are the
probability parameters in the choice
distribution
presented as the frequency of different
critters as a function of time is that
correct
yes i think i i think yes i mean
uh here in this situation you don't
assume that the players can play
mixed strategies in this situation you
think that the
players or the replicators are using
always the same pure strategy
and only their proportion in the
population can
vary no i understand but so the the
generalization of this would be
okay so sorry just
quickly there's there's a way in what
you were saying is right stephen in the
sense that
with as these population uh fly around
that the the strategy
you're going to face is changing because
you're
you're facing a population that's a
different set of strategies in it which
is the same as facing a
an opponent with that uh point in the
mixed strategy space
right so but but you're still keeping
your strategy fixed in each of these in
each of these cases so the the
evolutionary pressure is on the guy with
this thick strategy
but he's it's like he's playing again
because he's playing as the whole
population it's like he's playing as a
mixed strategy opponent with different
changing mixed strategies so one could
imagine another case where in the choice
distribution
the values of the probabilities are
interpolating functions
or put the other way around there's an
interpolating function that returns
choice distributions
that would be a mixed strategy as a
function of time
does that make sense yeah i mean you'd
have to you have to specify
what the uh your that point the
populations that you're having
evolutionary pressures on are a
um a continuous distribution kind of set
rather than a uh
i guess it's poinsett right but but that
would be the case if you were
putting pressure on their probabilities
which are continuous
in which case you get stochastic
differential equations one would assume
right okay but so that's that's the
other you also can get a stochastic case
if you if you let the pairings be uh
instead of being pairings against the
expectation of the whole population if
you let the pairings be
you know random choices of who you're
meeting out of the population
you'll get a stochastic dynamic then too
all right look
my takeaway from this is point one
replicator dynamics is a separate
wrapper around these kernels point two
we need to think carefully about what
the representation of these
you know uh you know things were
considering
outcomes whereby outcome i mean in
general even something like this
interpolating function as a function of
time
because i mean game solver is always
just giving us one result correct
although i don't know what happens in
the iterated case so in game solve you
can
get a lot of
different equilibrium
i understand i understand but it's each
one it just sits there i mean it doesn't
there's no it's not something where
there's a time series for example no no
that there is no time dependence there
right whereas an iterated game there
would be a time series
yes and also and also you need to
specify an initial condition
so this is this is another uh extra
feature
here okay which one should we look at
next we look at learn strategy
yeah learn strategy uh these are
basically um approximative solutions
uh for for games uh we touch those i
think this can be
uh implemented in game solve
i mean you can ask for so it's just like
a newton approximation or something
except it's not
newton it's something different yes yes
the one the one thing that we have to
leave some room for here is the
possibility of some of this you know um
plugging in more general algorithms we
talked a little bit last time about this
you know being able to plug into
also the machine learning framework
stuff or um uh yes
some of the net change stuff and so
forth um because people are definitely
interested in whether or not they can
have like just
typical online learning strategies uh uh
and drop one of them into this
so we don't have anything in the in the
um
in the game solve stuff that puts that
so deep inside that people can't have
sort of kernel like control over
what adaptive algorithm they want to try
it with
well so presumably what happens is there
is a um
i don't know what it's called it's a you
know game iteration function or
something
inside game solve
or you know game i don't know whether
it's game solution function game
iteration function
whatever where it's being given
i mean what will be the analog of that
in for example one of our iterative
uh minimization things roger
um well it's we've
packaged that all down at the method
level
yeah yeah for most you know because yeah
but here what we want to be able to do
is to expose
the thing on which you essentially do a
single game play or something
if we're doing well i'm not sure how
that quite works so there's two two
separate things
one is you might want to have you know
the the game evolve kind of thing of
doing your discrete trajectories of it
um but the other is you do want to have
something like method like control or
anything that's a learned strategy
um i think those are two different ends
of the spectrum one you want to be able
to just you know um
do something more explicitly just give
me a single trajectory evolve this
and the other is you want to be able to
specify your
your learned strategy algorithm to use
this or that um
function or adaptation method fashion
ethan our live stream is commenting that
net train
should be able to learn policies
yeah wrong wrong team to talk about that
in but uh
i mean this is we're talking here about
i would assume the analog of
a net train policy being able to be at
least supplied
if not learned
okay let's let's um
yeah commenter game repository yes yes
we
we're talking about that in other words
to be able to have named
games of which prisons dilemma and
you know these things are i think we
talked about that last time
yes and there are at least listed in the
end of this
okay okay all right fine coalitional
games what on earth are these
did we talk about these last time no no
this is where we stopped
um and so this is this is also
usually uh treated under game theory but
it's a very different concept i think
uh in this case you can imagine that
there are some players
and they can form coalitions and
the the question is that how much gain
they can
earn if they are in this coalition or in
that coalition
so basically the mathematical structure
of a coalitional game
is what i would say a measure which
associates real numbers to subsets
of a given player set
so they're mixing strategies from
different players
they're getting to do strategic
cooperation with each other where you
know i'll play this strategy if you play
that strategy and then
the payoffs we each get we get to share
among ourselves i see yes
so we get to make side payments to each
other within our coalition in order to
coordinate our strategies and try to get
a better outcome for our joint set
at the expense of the other players of
the game that aren't in our collision
so uh yeah here so so the other thing
like before steven we modeled
individuals
here we modeled groups so the other ones
are called non-cooperative or
non-coalitional
i see cooperative games i've heard of i
just haven't heard of coalitional games
i think it's the same yes this is the
same
um okay but so
in that case we need some representation
for one of these coalitions that has
you know if i'm not mistaken so
previously
you had it's like saying we've got
labels of a
you know of a vector that are dimensions
one two three but this is now a
combination of those dimensions
is that right yes so basically uh
a possible coalition is a subset of
players
and that's it it's not it's not weighted
the subset is not weighted
no i see but each of them has to
they also have a strategy or strategies
that they're agreeing on so the player
is you know the coalition set is just
the set of players that group
and then but the the the rest of the
specification what the coalition is is
what strategies they're all following
and how they're dividing their
joint payoff so so uh so mathematically
and
and then x symmetrically so a
coalitional game is really just a set
function
which associates uh real numbers to
subsets
and then uh you are right that you can
generate uh coalitional games from
from non-cooperative games but
i mean there are separate modes how you
can do that
but but in the end this is this measure
this this this collisional game this set
function
is a separate entity and a separate
object and then you can
you can manipulate that and then analyze
that
without any reference to the original
game so what is your proposed design for
this
so here i would say that there can be
a coalitional game object which is
which contains set function which
uh associates real number to subsets
and the set of the players if you scroll
down a little bit
to yes
uh a little down
uh so here is for example here here is
this
cg3 for example this is uh
this is something what i used as a
coalitional game
uh there is in the end there is the set
of players
one two three and there is a there is a
set function
here there are sharply values if you
scroll a little down then i
uh then i uh games some
uh a little more i gave some uh
visual visuals okay so this is a post
set
this is a representation of a post set
yes and here the size
the size of the the circles
are proportional to the payoffs of the
of the coalition
i see so if everybody gets together they
have the biggest payoff in this case
yes
[Music]
so wait a minute so for a given set of
strategies you can make one of these
kind of weighted hassi diagrams
to represent what people will be getting
in each of their different subsets
is that true yes so
there are different ways how you can
construct for example a standard
one is this alpha optimal
is that means that let's say you form a
coalition
and then you assume that everybody is
against you
everybody is against your coalition so
what is the minimum payoff
what you can gain if you join forces
into that coalition
uh you can ask this question and then
associate
this answer for every subset and that's
and that's how you can define for
example a coalitional game
derived from a multiplayer game
okay so i mean one thing
i mean it's quite separate thing but i
mean the visualization of these post
sets is something that seems to come up
multiple times it probably deserves its
own approach
but so i i i didn't see this
visualization anywhere else i just
thought that it could be nice to do that
or maybe intuitive more intuitive what
what
i used this actually bizarrely in the
the thing that i did about
the empirical meta-mathematics of euclid
recently i used exactly the same
visualization idea
yes i i mean for coalitional games i
don't
i didn't see it right something like
that
um usually if you scroll a little up
usually people are using these these
subs
so these these other forms this is
something what's happening if you have
three players
then the natural question is that if you
if everybody is joining in the grand
coalition
that's okay that they earn a lot of
money or something some
some transferable utility but how do you
want to
divide those utilities between players
and this is the main question
uh in in coalitional games uh the
the blue area represents for the core
which is a kind of division where
nobody thinks that if uh
he or she would would go out from the
coalition
would get a better position and
the blue dot is the chapli voy you and
there are
other many many concepts about that the
problem is that
if you have three members then it's
simply like this
if you have four then this is in three
dimensions
and if you are you have more players
then
there the dimensionality of these
objects grow
and it's very hard to visualize but i
mean in a sense this is a similar thing
you know when you have these regions
roger how does this compare to
like solutions to linear programming
problems and things like that
in other words the way that we'd specify
i don't even know how we
specify that i mean if you have some
complicated simplex
thingy okay maybe first of all we have a
simplex in any dimension
uh and this this is just a simple extent
yes
right uh but the linear programming i
mean you
any optimization you get the optimum
value
and you get a uh the optimum argument
the location where that value is
attained
right the odd max or whatever yeah
i mean so so that your nucleolus thing
whatever that thing is i don't know what
that is but
this this region here where everybody
should be friends type thing
um that presumably is described by a set
of inequalities
yes is that true yes and so
and the fortunate thing is that the
linearity is not ruined
if you have more players so in every
dimension this will be
actually a polygon yeah
so in other words the thing that this
could potentially return
is i mean we don't have a package
collection of inequalities it's just a
list of inequalities for us right roger
yeah i mean logical combination of
inequalities
right so that would be what we how we
would return this thing
and in some sense this is but is it
i didn't hear that is it always linear
joseph said yes
yes and
um but i mean and then to actually get
this picture
you're doing what a region plot how do
you you want the region that satisfies
all those inequalities
well actually some of these questions
are answered already in this
transferable utility package
what is already implemented in
mathematica there is this link for that
this
tu games
so i had no time to merge this with that
but
there are many uh functionalities
already
oh okay that's nice wow and this is
this is written by uh by an author who
who
has a similar book on the topic
so cool okay well be in touch with this
person
is this but this is a very old oh
created 2005
maybe from even earlier thing
if you see this pdf for example then you
you see some examples
there is this too okay well it seems
like you should be in contact with that
person and um uh
all right but but let's go let's go down
we're going to run out of time here but
let's look at a little bit of iterated
games
um is that the last big topic
here yes this is the last
oh boy okay
um
okay okay so let's try to understand
this
so as i understand i mean when i've
tried to understand this in the past
a given at a given moment a given player
could have is applying a function to the
complete history of all previous game
plays
is that not correct yes correct this is
this is a behavior strategy with perfect
recall okay
but so so in general it's just a
function that gets applied
to all previous
results whatever that means correct
and again let's understand how does this
relate
to the whole kind of reinforcement
learning
story and so on do we understand that
[Music]
i mean in a sense that's building up
you know as the robot pokes around the
world
trying different things it is
effectively building up
a model of what's going to happen in
different cases which i think is the
same type of thing as you're trying to
do here if i'm not mistaken
well i think this is a restricted
version of of of a behavior strategy
so in this behavior strategy you can
assume that you
know all the possible moves for you and
all the possible moves for your
opponents as well
and based on that you can construct the
function
if you do if the game is very
complicated and
maybe the action sets are too big then
maybe
you you don't assume that you you only
take into account in the past what kind
of payoffs you you get or what kind of
rewards you get
and and only
so i'm not an expert but but you try to
find the optimum between
between exploration and exploitation
and do those kind of things but i mean
i mean so for example iterated prison's
dilemma sort of standard case
you know one of the things so i know
uh you know the bob axelrod's
experiments for example where
he's looking at different possible
strategies that can be
and i always thought that was kind of a
hokey thing because
you know in my world at least you can
actually enumerate explicitly different
possible programs to apply
and i don't know what's the measure on
the space of programs on space
strategies or something
and if you are looking at i mean i don't
really understand how you can make
statements
about uh okay how do you typically
parameterize these strategies
because i mean the parameterization that
says you get a bunch of random students
i don't know why it doesn't professors
but um to uh
uh you know to program up various
strategies and see who wins type thing
um is seems like a you know in a world
at least the one that i'm used to where
you can start enumerating all possible
programs
i mean i think i did an example of this
sometime but
but my question is how do people
typically parameterize these strategies
well i think there are some strategies
which have parameters usually which
maybe you can say that okay the simplest
one
is that regardless of the history it
uses a
random strategy for example or or even a
pure strategy that's the simplest one
then you can say that it looks back
looks back
one or it looks back too in that case
you can parametrize this by a markov
chains
but in practice what happened in these
tournaments for example and there is a
python package
for for x-ray tournaments there you have
named
strategies around okay i think that's
crazy i mean i understand i'm sorry i i
think that's
i i'm amazed that people haven't done
this better by now
i mean this was a this was a this was a
trivial experiment that i did once
where this is playing you know using
cellular automata as strategies right
and at least
there it's not a question of name
strategies or ones programmed by some
random group of students
it's you can actually enumerate possible
algorithmic things
and this has certainly been done with
looking at all the possibilities and
there's even results like if you look
simplest one look back only things that
uh
rules that are uh in a sense dumber than
tit-for-tat work better than tit for tat
and so on
um okay uh fine the person who's done
the most on this i think is martin novak
but harvard in the center for evolution
of dynamics
um but he's done a lot of special facial
game theory but i know yeah
right now i know him the
um although he's in
unfortunately in retreat right now but
uh
the um
so here that so what i proposed here
is that if you have a game which you can
take as a game kernel for example
and you enumerate a finite set of
behavior strategies which is exactly
a function taking the game history
and also you need to specify here who
are you so which player
are you then
they can they can compete on they can
play with each other
and then basically this set of behavior
strategies
and the game kernel can generate
a new pay-off structure
and and see what would happen for
example if tft
was playing against dft if random was
playing against random etc etc but it's
up to you what kind of behavior
strategies you list
um right so so the basic point is we
have to be able to feed into one
a strategy is a function we have to have
a nice clean way to specify the state of
the world
for that function yes right and then
that function
then essentially what we're providing
here is the analog of nest list
yes that's basically all we're doing
because we're just saying
you at each step you shovel in all the
stuff and you
do all these whatever it is n square
different
comparisons or something between these
different players if i'm not mistaken
and then we get out some new state is
that right
yes so the game history will build up
gradually and
always uh those that game history will
be feeded
with these behavior strategies yes
right but what i'm is it correct if you
have n players you've got
is it correct to if it isn't a a
cooperative game of some kind
that you've got n squared different
individual
comparisons to make is that right or not
no
um i mean in every step but then
you have an infinite possibility for
behavior strategy
but am i right that at every step you're
playing one against one
is that right or are you playing one
against all no
uh this this can be generalized so in in
in these prisoners dilemma one against
one but in the general case it's perfect
perfectly well defined that n players
uh are are playing the game
i see so in other words what you're
saying is but you can have different
ways of specifying how they play it
right it can be that each person plays
one uh once against each other players
uh every
round or you can have them randomly
paired you can have them set up laid out
in space there's all kinds of ways you
could do population edits yeah
the simplest is just where there's two
playing each other iterated
yes so similarly uh as seen in
replicator dynamics this this population
grouping can vary
yes but but also in this case
whereas replicated dynamics is an ode in
this case this is an iterated function
correct basically yes
yes i mean presumably there's a version
of this
the complication is that it is an
integrated function but the move vector
that you're that you're uh
uh taking in to decide your next move is
a growing length list
i understand you can have strategies
only look back a certain distance but if
they're
if they're not finite lookback ones then
the complexity of the input thing gets
larger and larger yes yes obviously
right i mean it's just a function that
takes a list
basically or in general in a continuous
case it could take an interpolating
function i would assume
yes and a mini player thing could take
them you know a
whole set of move vectors right you
could have a move matrix for all the
pass moves all the
other players right but each one is
separate right i mean each in other
words it's the
succession of states of the game it's
the time series effectively
of states of the game where at each
time step you know what each player did
yes correct so but each player
the only place where those interact is
at the current time
you're doing you are looking at that
whole history under the current state
and you're deciding on the basis of that
what your next step is going to be
yes but in general and this is where i
suppose it gets kind of complicated i
mean i don't know there must be
i'm sure somebody has done this
fanciness you must be able to have some
integral differential equation
that looks back at the complete time
series
and then says based on that it applies
some
some i mean because the differential
case is an instantaneous
state of the game and what the
instantaneous next move is
but if you're going to take count of
infinite history i would assume that
there's some integral you take over the
infinite history with some appropriate
kernel and so on and that must be
the simplest case of that you described
the mark markov type thing
is like that's the discretized version
of that where there would be some
you know finite sub kernel support
going back some number of steps yes it
would be an integral equation
basically right if you if you want to
make it
a differential so if you want to make an
infinitesimal version of this do people
do that or is that like
still in the future well i'm not aware
of that
but okay i mean because because you also
have to parameterize i mean the
difficulty here
is that you know parameterizing
algorithms is a tough business
i mean people yeah the usual usual
usual parameters used here is to start
from the shortest look back strategies
and then go to longer look back
strategies and that way you can have a
natural way of counting through them in
terms of their complexity and then you
can you know arrive at theorems
like if i've if i've got a longer look
back than the person i'm playing against
then
if the game goes on long enough i can
learn his whole uh
i can learn his input output tree and
and you know predict his moves and so
forth
um but that's the typical way it's
parameterized is just what are the
allowed look back links and how do they
vary across the players that's the
typical way people go through this
if you allow infinite look back both for
all players then
you're right it's just it's incredibly
complicated and you can't tell which
strategy you're talking about
okay but i mean in in that case really
it is just a packaging of nestles that
we're talking about here
um
yes yes actually it's not even that it's
it's the
sorry uh it's the thing what do we have
we have i mean for example nest wildlist
allows you to say
how far back you want to look to
determine that a test for example
yeah we've done like uh ncaa summer
school projects about this sort of stuff
people have just
built it out of nest list and and had
different ways of
the complexity comes from how they want
to as you say enumerate all the
strategies and how far they want to
push in the strategy set to look at all
the different possible combinations
um but but the underlying um evolving
function is
it's just a very into nestles with
appropriate uh
appropriate logical arguments for it
okay fine but but so
again i just want to understand the
distinction here because this is the
discrete case
and then which is you know
but then the replicated dynamics is the
continuum analog of this
for certain simple strategies correct
yes so i think here the main invention
that you can use
behavior or strategies in the replicator
dynamics usually the strategies are not
looking back or not
taking into consideration i understand
they're just the instantaneous state
that they're taking a derivative as
opposed to some integral differential
you know some
integral kernel that looks back some i
mean this would be the analog
i don't know in in um uh
there must be in control theory there
must be a similar kind of thing
roger how does that work where you look
back
where you either know the instantaneous
state of the system or you also know the
history
um yeah so often
the way you formulate it is some kind of
goal
so it's like some some integral for
instance or some
that you want to minimize or maximize
and then you have constraints for how
the system needs to evolve
you know like you can't you know it has
to follow newton's dynamics or something
so there are constraints differential
constraints
yeah then you compute the optimal
control that that
that that maximizes or minimizes that
goal
that integral and so for simple cases we
already have it
uh in the general case this leads to you
know you can compute it in the general
case
uh richard bellman and so on
shows how you can do that with dynamic
programming dynamic optimization
but it has a cursive dimensionality
problem
so how does that relate to finding
optimal strategies here
it's the same course of dimensionality
probably no but everything's the same
problem though
i think it is but i i need to dig in
deeper okay all right but
i think all these three things that we
bring up control
optimal control iterated games
and reinforcement learning are
variants of the same perspectives onto
the same
kind of problem right so for us though
the thing that will be really nice is
you know install a pid controller or
something
in this game whatever that might mean
yeah and i think in economics people do
worry
i mean do think in that kind of way also
by the way so here's a very
very elementary way that i can describe
what you were just saying how to look
back
so pid is the oldest simplest possible
controller that you could imagine
it's pretty dumb but it's not too bad
either
so it has pid means proportional
proportional to the error i means
integral so that's
integration of the error and d means
derivative
and so that that integral it keeps track
of
you know how much deficit that you have
aggregated up um and it will
zero that out eventually you know but it
keeps track of that integral
right so that's an analog of a
continuous version of the saturated game
yes but with a one player i mean that's
effectively a one player game playing
against
nature or something yes
but you could imagine that's right you
know these iterative games part of the
interest is you know can you use
uh pass game history to infer the other
person's strategy and they're
for you know be able to predict it
better um and and that's what the longer
look back things can effectively wind up
doing that you
can't quite do in the in the nature case
a pid controller its integral goes back
to to the beginning of time is that true
yes i see so so
but that's i mean it's that's trivial to
represent as a state
so i'm saying you you don't actually
have to you don't actually compute it i
mean no i understand you just accumulate
the integral you accumulate error
but i mean presumably you could have two
pid controllers playing against each
other
isn't that what happened i i'm trying to
remember that
there's a famous story about edison and
the time when when
he was trying to first get the electric
you know two electrical generators and
they were connected in some way
and they repelled in phase and one of
them eventually blew up
and i haven't heard his that story but
that's very true
so you often have i mean this is this
can happen today too you have um
like multiple on a ship for instance you
can have multiple edges and the question
is how do you coordinate them
uh and yes there are plenty of ex
i've heard plenty of stories where they
more or less kind of burn each other out
but so is that not the continuous analog
of games against controllers
don't know i think it must be something
very similar right because it's
it's at each point
well okay but i mean for us
the main point is to make compatibility
between these
at least three different views of the
same
type of problem yeah
i mean the goals
and the audiences are slightly different
but yeah there should definitely be
bridges
absolutely right because i mean you know
but if we unified we might make a
product that nobody wants to use
oh i agree i agree but the issue is how
do you take
a pid controller and stick it in an
economic game
theory thing how do you no
but you know economists are you know
i've
sort of shown the way there they they
use a lot of control theory actually i
know yeah
i know but i mean the question then is
how do we make sure that our control
theory functionality
slots into our game theory functionality
right
yep and um and the neural net similarly
uh
you know because again it's i suppose
the question then i mean so
various ways around one is to use a
neural net to learn
some iterated game which
should be possible as now that we're
working on sequence
related sequence prediction and so on
you should be able to just plug sequence
predict
into one of these iterated games in
other words sequence predict should be
the function
that is that function that is fed to say
what should you do next
since sequence predict will take a
sequence as input
well it takes a collection of historical
sequences
hmm yeah i'm not sure how that should
work go ahead
the interesting point is that uh it's
better if you don't
optimize always for the next step or for
the
for the present but you also
try to figure out what would be a nice
time horizon
i mean uh in in some ways it sounds like
corporate strategy
okay yes go ahead please so so the thing
is that
uh the strategies which enforce the
other player
to to cooperate for example are
are better off
naturally in every instance the the
better would be
to find find a place where they can
defect but if they you know
there is a story that if you if you
start this
prisoner's dilemma for example in the
beginning
the defectors are winning and then
gradually these
tits for that strategies are somehow
cleaning up
the the
players and and then
after after transient period
cooperation starts to be more rewarding
we have run out of time here um this was
very interesting
uh there's a question for purkinje about
apply a pid tuning method to a game like
the ziegler nichols method
i don't know if anybody here knows what
that is that's a particular
it's in our pid tune function it's a
it's a method
to automatically uh
tune the parameters of a pid so you have
the world the plant and you
automatically derive what's
what's a good controller you know i do
wonder
i don't think that our machine learning
team and people working on sequence
predict
have probably ever even heard of a pid
controller
but is it obvious that pid control
shouldn't be and things like that
shouldn't be
possible methods for sequence predict
that might even work better than some of
these fancy neural net things
um yeah i mean we should look at it but
i mean there there are there are already
a very standard predictors like common
filters
is you know kind of this standard
predictor used in control theory
and derived there i understand but i
don't know whether the common filter
approach has been ported
to i mean okay look it's the same type
of thing
as you know is it really just logistic
regression or is it fancy
you know neural networks right exactly
right
and um this is the same type of thing i
have no idea and it could very well be
that our sequence predict function would
just get better
if we were to put inside i mean but
you're hitting all the things that i'm
planning for us to focus in on okay fine
good well that's good um all right well
so it seems like we have a nice
extra leg to that with joseph's work
here on game theory
yeah um and uh it's very very promising
um uh okay we had a bunch of questions
on our
comments on our live stream i suppose i
should just look at them for a second
uh ethan is pointing us to a
game theory library which we should look
at um
comments about applicability to
reliability engineering
um
what did it say about reliability i know
it's just other reliability stuff people
often often treat those as game theories
where they imagine
you know the worst case scenario is like
you're playing against a hostile nature
who can make strategic moves against you
to break your
um fake your systems so they they use a
game theory context to look at
reliability because
instead of thinking that rangers can act
randomly you think that nature is going
to act strategically
and that that it sort of gives you
something which is stress dust worst
case
i see it doesn't sound sounds like a
pretty good idea
this this this can be very naturally
implemented in this game
transform where you can you could assume
that the
the opponent's payoff is for example
uh minus your is the opposite of your
payoff
and then you can also transform
utilities to
the regrets which is which is a better
um you know set up if you if you are
thinking that denature is uh
english but that's interesting joseph
but the thing is
what stephen would say next or if he's
timed out now but
is we have a whole big framework for
reliability
of systems and the question is can it
plug in there
somehow of course right
yeah comment here from uh sun on the
live stream
about neural nets might achieve the same
as things like pid controllers but they
don't explicitly integrate
and that's true i mean neural nets are
uh you know in some ways
the you know they're a lower level and
therefore more generic approach
but the place where you put all the
trickery in is in the encoding functions
and so on and i could certainly imagine
actually this is an interesting idea
okay so we have the notion of a net
encoder
right question is what is a net encoder
for a sequence
well one obvious knight encoder which
i'm sure we do not have is the net
encoder that integrates
right in other words you know you feed
in the classical
you know common filter-ish kinds of
things or
pid kinds of things by basically
putting them in a net encoder then
letting the neural nets
operate on the features that are
generated from you know
after you've already used that kind of
classical methodology
that's probably something worth looking
at i mean the fact is that our
sequential right now is pretty bad
you know our classify and predict
functions are quite good
and you know you you feed in things that
you think might work
and they typically work better than you
expect whereas
sequence prediction has you know we
really don't do that well on sequence
prediction
not that anybody does but it might be
that these you know
if we could put in these classical
methods as encoders that might be very
helpful
okay i need to go um good good stuff
guys
and thanks to folks on the live stream
also um
and uh until the next time